hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're going
to be looking at the black mark Deemer
cam bit and for anyone that's been
following me knows that I'm a very
aggressive player and I really enjoy
gambits and this is one of my favorite
game it so I wanted to take a look at it
and it starts out with pawn to d4 pawn
to d5 pawn to e4 already giving away a
pawn in the very beginning of the game
pawn takes on e4 and then Knight to c3
you can transpose into this and a few
variations so a lot of players like to
play the Queen's pawn opening with Queen
to d4 but a lot of times they might not
play pawn to e4 here because they
already have an opening move in their
repertoire like the Queen's Gambit line
with pawn to c4 but a lot of players
really hate playing the Scandinavian
myself included so a lot of times if you
see pond e4 and black responds pawn to
d5 you can now play pawn to d4 we
transpose into the same black barty more
gambit after they take on e4
then we can play Knight to c3 and it's
the same thing so even if you don't like
playing it when you start out with d4 if
you start out with e4 like a lot of
players like myself you come across a d5
you can still transpose into it now from
here blacks going to play Knight to f6
simple development move and at the same
time he's defending this pawn that we're
attacking since black is up in material
he's going to want to hold on to that
material which is very important now
from here
white has a few options but his main
line that you're going to see is pawn to
f3 and from here Black's going to take
on f3 and White has two options from
here to take with his knight or to play
the writer game it which is Queen takes
on f3 and the first one we're going to
take a look at is Knight takes on f3 now
if you just take a look at it right away
white is down a pawn in material but
this is a very aggressive line from
white so if you're more of a defensive
player you don't like to give up
material early on in the game I
highly recommend not playing this
because it is one of the most aggressive
lines that you can play and it's not as
easy to attack as your Danish gambit
where you have all your bishops lined up
at the King you're really going to have
to be very creative as a chess player to
win playing the blackmart diem or gambit
now with that said it is very lethal and
if you do practice and know a lot of
lines you can play play this line very
well so with that said from here black
has a few lines that he can play if he
moves his bishop down to g4 then we're
going to play our pawn to h3 we're going
to try to chase the bishop up the board
a lot of times players won't trade off
their bishops early on because they want
to have that bishop pair so if he does
continue to bring his bishop back then
we're going to just continue up the
board with pawn to g4 as you can tell
already
we've weakened our King side we are not
castling on the King side from here more
times than not anytime you play the
black Mardy Murie ambit probably 90
times out of 100 you're going to castle
on the Queen side it's one of the things
that you always want to think about
they're going to castle on the Queen
side when you play this now there is one
variation where you may castle on the
King side and that is if instead he
instead of playing the bishop if he
plays his Knight to c6 which is a very
common development move bringing his
knight to c6 attacking our pawn on d4 we
can now bring our Bishop to b5 pinning
this Knight down at the same time we can
now castle on the King side which is
completely safe and at the same time
kind of like the King's gambit where
this F file is semi open bar rook this
is going to be a very good and
aggressive game for us but if we play
this more times than not we're going to
be focusing on the King side we're going
to be focusing on this F file we can
bring our Bishop back if we need to to
c4 we're going to be eyeing on this f7
square it's very important if we do
Castle kingside which we don't often
it's going to kind of change up what
we're
looking to do when we cast on the
queenside instead we're going to focus
on the D file we're going to focus on
not allowing the King to castle at all
but if we do play this variation we're
going to castle on the King side and
look to eye down on this F file very
important if instead from the beginning
if you want to play an even more
aggressive opening then the knight takes
on f3 then I recommend the rider gambit
and the rider gambit is queen takes on
f3 and from here blacks going to take on
d4 and as you can already tell we've
given up two pawns we're down two pawns
in material and so this is an even more
aggressive opening but at the same time
I feel like this for me it plays better
into my style but it really is going to
keep black on its toes because a lot of
times if you play this a lot of black
players are going to look at you and
think you're [ __ ] because it looks
like White has absolutely no idea what
they're doing just giving up pawns
bringing out their Queen early and
doesn't look like white knows what
they're doing when in fact this actually
plays very well for white so from here
why it's going to continue bringing his
Queen to e3 attacking this Queen from
black on d4 and trying to get out of the
way and as you can see here we've
already moved all of our pieces from the
BC and D 1 files so this automatically
tells us we're going to be cancelling on
the Queen side I know I told you before
we're going to cast on the Queen side
but specifically now since we have all
our pieces out of the way we're looking
to castle on the Queen side and then
we're going to bring our rook to d1
we're going to just eye down this D file
the entire time our goal is to not let
the King move from here specifically not
let the King move his pawn out of the
way move his dark square bishop at
castle on the Queen on the King side so
we really want to keep it at bay from
here there's two moves that you may see
from black here one which would really
like to see tip as Queen came to b4 and
this is actually
the trap that I'm going to discuss in
another video and that's the Hollister
trap so you definitely want to make sure
you take a look at that trap video but
the most common move that you will see
in the best move that you will see is
Queen to g4 now once we see this we're
just going to continue to castle on the
Queen side we're going to let the Queen
from black move around lose some tempos
at the same time we're just going to
develop rapidly while black just sits
there and starts to he's up in material
but at the same time he hasn't done much
as you can see if you were to trade off
right now and we take with our knight or
down to pawns and material but if you
look at the board it's actually in my
opinion much easier to play from white
we have both of our Knights centered on
the board easily developed we have our
Queen Castle down the kink Queen side
with our rook eyeing down on this fully
opened e-file and at the same time we
can bring our LightSquared Bishop easily
into the action we can bring our other
rook into the action we have a lot of
attacking prowess again in chess it's
not about who's up in material it's
about who can attack the opponent's king
in this case we can attack the
opponent's King very easy so from here
we have a lot of fighting options really
depends on where black goes but keep in
mind if you look at this position
there's a lot of different things that
white can do so if you play this use
your creativity there's a lot of
different fighting lines that you have
here but just from looking at this you
can tell that white has a lot of
fighting and very aggressive lines so
this is the black Mardy more game bit
make sure you take a look at the
hollister trap because it is and plays a
very important role especially if you
play the Ryder gambit which is the
aggressive opening that we take the look
at when Queen takes on f3 so take a look
at that if you haven't already
subscribed to the channel please do that
if you haven't checked out the website
the chess website calm pretty easy hope
you guys enjoyed this video and I'll see
you guys next video see